first up he is the ending winning writer
inaccurate star is in better call saul
which premiered this week on amc and the
new york times bestseller author of his
new memoir comedy comedy comedy drama
bob odenkirk
[Applause]
[Music]
i was thrilled when i you uh thank you
for having me on please we're always
such a great supporter of me and david
doing oh doing our mr show honestly it
was bill it was like the great did
anyone remember oh are you okay come on
study your comedy oh no
or or youtube it yeah youtube yes
although you know what that show and
again you're right i was the biggest fan
either you had legions of fans for that
show um one thing about that which might
not work on youtube youtube shows
snippets the great thing about your show
unlike every other sketch show all the
sketches were connected yeah i mean you
know starting out live does one sketch
and then another one it has a completely
different sketch yeah first there's five
commercials but yeah right right but
yours everyone i thought that was genius
thank you an innovative well we were
trying to copy python is that where that
goes absolutely yeah right of course
they had gilliam's animations but we
would just make a sketch go into the
next sketch just to keep that energy
going and keep things silly and uh and
it was great fun to do i think we did it
right a couple times we did 33 shows
that's all but packed a lot of ideas
into them
and uh there's a great episode where
mediocrity
is a monster that kind of just courses
through the whole episode riding a big
bike yeah i mean it worked on a level
i've never seen before and not not to
say that other sketch shows aren't good
i mean you worked on
many of them snl i worked on snl and you
know it's interesting
there's a roster of like really
impressive people
who have worked at snl and bombed out
there larry david sarah silverman yeah
our dearly departed gilbert godfrey yeah
uh you zach galifianakis
julia louis dreyfus it's amazing yeah
and then of course this is not to say
that the people who
how we've seen on that show that weren't
all so fantastic because they were it's
just like there's two different types
of people almost in comedy what do you
think makes that difference between the
person the kind of person who
survives and thrives at a show like snl
and those who don't um
i think i'm particularly um
dangerous and intelligent
i'm a wonderful
brain i'm unique and special
no uh they're they're better than me and
i'm slower than that
and that's what it is no i i just you
know that show has these demands and
needs that uh to satisfy the audience
with a big
big presentation and a kind of a
confidence um
and i just didn't have that it's broader
it's just broader it's broader i know
but i like broad comedy too i just
couldn't do it bill i just was too young
you know a lot of people that's their
first job and they just don't know their
voice yet and the show's demands are so
like immediate and intense you do it
every week you got to put it together in
two days and i just i just couldn't pull
it off i was there for three and a half
years i learned everything i know there
i got paid for being there and they got
nothing out of me
i mean i i wrote the motivational
speaker but that was a year after i left
but we got a lot out of you now thank
you buddy that's what yeah i took
i took what i learned i had 20 other
writers that's right you know i took
what i learned and i came to l.a and i i
made a career well i i think it also has
to do and i've saw this in your book you
think there should be an element of
anger
in comedy for me yeah absolutely i mean
not that there can't it can't just be
silly we like that too yeah yeah i do
too yeah but to me i'm the same way you
are like the best kind of comedy yeah
has that there's a little nutritious
value that doesn't exist everywhere
right it doesn't end with everybody
going we're just kidding it's okay okay
it's kind of got a little edge and
it and i i needed that and i loved it
and that's what i saw in monty python
and and even in snl in many sketches and
certainly the early snl had you know it
was a generational thing those first
couple years if you weren't part of that
generation you didn't get it right and i
love that i love that in comedy i love
that there's a show that you have to
find your way into the brain of the
people who made it
and yet you never really wanted to be a
stand-up
you know
bill you
are a stand-up and you're a great
stand-up and for me it was always such a
finisher i really are
and but it's because
have you seen my latest special adulting
it's running now yeah yeah
this is my guess
did i play guests tonight bill maher
he's got a special adult thing please
watch it and thank you you can go now
thank you it's so great
you know i i came up in chicago during
the comedy boom which you must remember
you started then right well you're
talking about late 70s early 80s yes
every city including mid-sized cities in
america had sometimes multiple comedy
clubs it was crazy it was great for a
little while like anything yeah and then
we ruined it
but i just you know i couldn't i i think
i uh i couldn't handle the
confrontational nature of standup i mean
a lot of times a stand-up show was a
fight between the audience and the
performer yeah and i was always of the
feeling like i would get out there i'd
start my act if they didn't like it i
was
i was like okay we'll see ya bye you
know like right away like you you don't
like this that's okay there's other
people exactly what larry did be like
yes that's exactly what larry david used
to do that's right i remember seeing him
at the improv obviously so much fun
there's a certain
genius that's also embedded in that
you were you were impatient with the
audience being maybe too broad yeah and
more drunk
drunk which makes you stupid makes you
stupider you know and not being able to
appreciate the subtlety of what you were
doing i mean you know you work on a
level sometimes i mean do you remember
the time
that you almost killed me
no i i'm serious you almost killed me in
aspen it was the ass there was an aspen
comedy festival for many years i
remember we had to go every year i
[ __ ] hated it i
aspen in february skiing i don't ski i
don't want to ski it's cold i don't want
to die in a tree
[Laughter]
the air is thin i never slept yeah it
was a nightmare right
you couldn't breathe and you did this
bit i went to we all had like a little
convention a little booth or something
was fun all the different shows you
could go right so i meant you're i
forget why you were doing it or what you
were doing yeah but you did this bit
where you were robert evans
[Music]
you're gonna do it again robert
robert evans says god and i remember
watching standing in this tent watching
you and i was laughing so hard and then
the air and i thought oh [ __ ] i'm going
to die at a comedy festival
from comedy by another comedian jesus my
son you never let me down
but people have to know who bob evans is
do they i think the cadence and the
voice is so funny with the sunglasses
and the hair they get the general it's
just that god has but it was a huge ego
yes did they do a good job with the
world
i tried
some people made a big bet
you know
uh it's a great way of thinking about
god he's just yes grinning and happy and
he acknowledges all the problems in the
world but for those who don't know
robert evans was this big producer
he was the godfather chinatown he was
but he was also this larger-than-life
figure and he had a book out at the time
called the kid stays in the picture
and the audio the version we used to
read tapes back then you put in your car
and you'd listen to it and it was just
the voice you did yeah about his and the
malibu life yeah you transferred it to
god all right now i've ruined it by
explaining it
but isn't it it's a baseball players do
me a favor don't pray to me through the
whole game
i'm probably not a fan of your team i
got 10 other games on the tv
you should you should revise i should do
we should do the whole thing yeah we'll
do the uh but see that's the other
reason that stand-up was so hard for me
is i couldn't tell my jokes more than
twice without
hating them
like they'd be a good joke and it'd be
like the second time i told her okay i
told it
tell each other you don't need you don't
need me to tell you again go spread that
word around
and uh i know but a stand-up a real pro
has to be able to do that tight 20
right that that core
thing i don't know if you do that but i
was always working bill on a tight zero
and i got there i got this it took me a
long time but i got there well i do a
tight 90.
i don't do 20s anymore when i do shows
but you know i mean that core
uh material that you bring through you
through the years well the see i found
the secret is people say like a are you
on tour i'm never on tour
i do two shows like saturday and sunday
i go home for a month and then i do two
more yeah and that way it's new but i'm
still practicing yeah yeah you know keep
it fresh you do happen to have a tv show
i don't know if you know about that no i
know
and a podcast now
but it's it's i find it very sort of
bittersweet that we are at the age now
because your book fantastic book comedy
comedy comedy drama thank you we're at
the age now where we are
imparting wisdom
you know i mean you wouldn't have
written a book when you were 35 right
you had didn't have enough wisdom right
and now you have wisdom yeah and you're
imparting it i'm trying to i mean i
don't i wish i'd learned more but the
little bit that i learned is in there so
please good luck finding it
but i did i mean mostly it's a book
about
thanks
thank you it's mostly just a book about
making your way and not quitting it's
showbiz and it's a numbers game and if
you keep at it and you keep looking for
opportunities and this wonderful
opportunity with better call saul is
something i never
pursued and bill it just came to me and
it's crazy you've never even read for it
right i never read for it i never took
an acting class uh so interesting don't
tell anyone this isn't
no no broadcasting
tell them all because they're wasting
their money
right i mean yeah it's so interesting
the way uh
to name another comedian from our past
richard belzer yeah same thing never
read for the part that he got we played
for so long yeah on um
whenever the [ __ ] that child
law and order yes is it yes he was
detective munch on many versions of the
show barry levinson the director just
said i know the same thing with you like
a smart creative director knows oh this
comedic guy with that mind is going to
be more interesting than an actor i
don't have to see him audition yeah i
just know i know i love that i love you
yeah yeah they loved you well here it is
put you in it like 14 years later i've
been playing this guy forever but right
and now it's coming to an end and this
is the final season right now right it's
our best season and it's it's been an
amazing both shows have given us so much
great entertainment thanks we thank you
for it thanks buddy bob odenkirk god
you